yeah
[Music]
blasts drown out the call to prayer
a day to celebrate the end of Ramadan is
marked by endless violence
many remain trapped as safe route open
then close including a British teacher
from Coventry there were three big booms
one was massive we just sort of lay here
me and my wife we didn't didn't actually
talk to each other
um
and we shook what do you and fellow
Brits feel about how the British Embassy
has approached us
I suppose I do it in two words it's gone
from
anger definitely there's lots of anger
in there
two uh comical
I think the thing between those two
is where most of us are at least the
Brits that I've talked to
we're not we're not very impressed I
think I put it that way people continue
to flee and volunteers are working
overtime to coordinate their safe
Passage went to the nice Army and rsf
are attacking each other my friend and I
are trying to find best passage for
people to leave their location to
another uh safer place he makes one of
many calls to a friend
asking if her road is safe to use mozap
has helped many to safety including
American researcher Rebecca her calls to
her Embassy were fruitless
I am livid at my Embassy I think that
their advice actively is going to hurt
people all of us Sudanese and foreigners
deserve safety and are at risk because
of this war and while foreigners have
been failed by their embassies we have
all been failed by the Sudanese generals
and foreign powers that placed us in
this situation
a week of Terror that has felt like a
lifetime for the millions who see no end
in sight
Sky News